there are many different misconceptions
in life many and one of the things
misconceptions tend to do is they tend
to prevent people from doing things that
could benefit them they say things oh my
god I don't know if I want to do this
because in their mind this is what they
believe it's what they don't do it so
the definition of a misconception
definition the meaning of misconception
is a thought or an opinion that is
incorrect because it is based on faulty
thinking or understanding so today I
want to clarify some of the
misconceptions about entrepreneurship
I'm writing on College Station Texas
which is the home of the Aggies Texas
A&M University these guys invited me to
come and speak to their but you know
their next class of entrepreneurship
have a program here called
entrepreneurship society and last time
when I was talking to these young
aspiring entrepreneurs they had so many
different misconceptions I have nine of
them I want to share with you so the
first one is this here's one of the
biggest misconception that I keep
hearing about entrepreneurs are born
constantly entrepreneurs are born you
are born an entrepreneur which is an
absolute lie if there ever was one yes
it's like saying one is born with a 40
inch vertical leap yes you're right
Larry Bird did not have a 40 inch
vertical leap so he cannot dunk like
LeBron Jets yes but that doesn't mean
you are born to be a basketball player
but you know Larry Bird is not that has
no meaning Jonah get you know Michael
Jordan was born to be a basketball
player but Steph Curry was not because
he's six 170 pounds you can't say that
because the guy's a tiny guy
Muggsy Bogues was a five three
basketball player five foot three inches
and he played the NBA nearly ten
something yards and it was pretty good
at it so the same goes to saying this
person's not meant to be an entrepreneur
because he's too shy this person is not
meant to be an entrepreneur because he
had a 1.0 GP in high school this person
is not meant to be an entrepreneur
because he has certain nationality or
skin of colors you know that no don't
buy it
it's misconception someone's trying to
persuade you that you can't become an
entrepreneur and it's not the truth it's
faulty thinking and you need to question
it you don't need to just say or this
guy on YouTube said that entrepreneurs
are born BS don't buy it it's a
misconception number two the second
thing is something I struggled with is
you have to cheat or steal to win as an
entrepreneur you do not you do not have
to cheat or steal as an entrepreneur
I've watched this for many many years
with my
I had to compete and some people did it
the right way some people did it the
wrong way
some people had shortcuts and every
single time there's a shortcut were
tempted everybody's tempted I was
tempted every time I'm sitting here
competing against the guy that's making
400 grand a month and I'm only making 30
grand a month and I'm 25 years old
whatever it is 26 years old and he's
doing certain things that I don't want
to do but if I have to compete with them
I have to do that to compete with them I
didn't do it he kept doing it he lost
his licenses we kept going now if I
would have done it I would also lost my
license you do not have to cheat or
steal to win in business you don't you
do not have to cheat or steal to win in
business people say that because it is a
way out for them to say I chose not to
be an entrepreneur because I am a noble
human being and because I'm a noble
human being I refuse to cheat us because
it's against my character that is not
true you don't have to cheat or steal to
become an entrepreneur there are laws
you break and me going straight to
prison number three they got lucky
they're so lucky thing and by the way I
talk about lucky quite a lot on one end
you know luck doesn't happen
accidentally
for example nobody is gonna go on a date
with a beautiful girl by not talking to
her you have to take action there's got
to be a conversation
no one closes a big sale without knowing
anything about their products because
the bigger the sell it is the more
educated a customer is you can't just go
to a customer and ask for $200,000 check
and I'm gonna say yes and you know you
know nothing about your products not
gonna happen you have to work your butt
off to get good at what you do you have
to work your butt off to become an
expert you have to marry you immerse
yourself on it you're gonna go through
certain breaking points that you don't
feel like doing anything you want to
throw in the towel those moments are
things that people don't see nobody sees
I'm in Hilton right now and I remember
one time we were on the tour last year
when we were doing the Entrepreneurship
tour we stopped by Conrad Hilton where
he you know accidentally bought this
building that I don't even it was a it
was a hospital it was a nurse it was
something it wasn't a hotel right he
bought this thing he turn it into a
hotel next thing you know started
growing theirs Hilton's in Iran and I'm
in Iran I've gone to Hilton when I was a
kid growing up Hilton was like insane we
don't know the stories I want Hilton
almost went out of business we don't
know the stories of his arguments with
his wife we don't know the times where
he's at a hotel room by himself
away from
birthday because he has to be at a
business meeting and he's absolutely
feeling crap about the fact that he
missed an event for his kid or baseball
you don't know those moments so you
can't say they got lucky there is no
there is a luck involved in business I'm
not telling you there isn't nothing
wrong with getting lucky but there's got
to be a lot of hard work before you get
lucky number four selfish
entrepreneurs are selfish entrepreneurs
are selfish you'll hear the word selfish
greedy and all they care about is money
quite regularly they're selfish they're
very selfish they're also all they care
about is themselves listen you can't
build a billion dollar company when you
build a billion dollar company the guy
that built a billion dollar company he
doesn't keep the billion dollars the
billion dollar company he probably keeps
50 million dollar salary per year let's
just say if you build a billion dollar
company now if you own a big part of it
sure the value of the company is yours
but if you grow your company grows two
billion dollars per year he takes 50
million dollar your income even that
people say that's greedy let's say it
takes a 50 million dollar income because
I'm picking the greediest see you can
think about he's taking a 50 million
dollar one company build a
billion-dollar company okay where does
that 950 million dollars go to you tell
me does that go in his pocket no it goes
to what it goes to employees it goes to
health care goes to building it goes to
lease it goes to construction it goes to
Long communication Internet servers
these are all jobs being created a
billion-dollar Empire is creating nine
hundred and fifty thousand dollars of
revenue to other people that lead to
taxes you can't be selfish and build a
big company you just cannot you can be
selfish and be a salesperson because all
you're doing is selling and it's all you
one person show one-man show because
it's all about you yes you can be
selfish I agree with you that's
impossible for you to build an empire
being selfish it's mathematically
impossible for you to build a big empire
being selfish math doesn't make sense
you can't win an NBA championship what
I'd have an assists you can't it's never
happened and it's never gonna happen
you can't win a baseball game without
having somebody that's double playing
the team catches the ball throw you
can't have it you can't have a no hit
you can't I can go in with any different
sports you cannot do it without having a
team that's selfish it just does not
work it is not gonna work that way not
in the world of business number five all
you need is a great idea product lot of
people message me and they say pack yes
what man
what's that then I got this product you
and I need to team up it's a
billion-dollar idea I promise you bro
you're gonna be a billionaire you can do
this I'm like you like you really think
in ideas what makes a billion dollar the
you think the idea is what makes it a
billion dollars really you think an idea
is an idea means nothing nothing you
know why because very few execute very
few execute and here's another thing
about ideas
there are many crappy products in the
world that are sold on the shelves of
Walmart many there are many crappy
products in the world that are sold in
Macy's and people buy and their products
suck there are many shirts that you go
by with the you know what he called the
strings are out with the shirts it's
just you know the strings it's just
terrible people buy why do they buy show
your idea that you have means nothing if
there's no execution ideas just an idea
there are many great ideas out there
executions the issue number six it's all
you need is to raise capital people say
Pat if I raise money man like less than
one kid is asking me I'm telling the fat
a million dollars right now I do this if
I heard every single time somebody told
me if I had a million dollar investment
I'd be a billionaire today everybody
wants to talk about if I had money in a
race capital it means nothing it means
nothing
it doesn't mean a little bit don't get
me wrong but you're not gonna get a race
I get messages path can you do a video
on how to raise capital I'll do a video
on how to raise capital can you do a
video on how to raise capital can you do
a video on how to raise capital I will
I'll definitely do that because if I
have a cap what I will do this this
distance is for my business and I'll
tell them I say have you ever won in the
past before who are you how hard you
work what's your track record what
relationships do you have what
associations do you have who needs to
bet on you would you bet on you why
should someone bet on you if you can
answer those questions you'll eventually
raise capital if you don't have that you
ain't getting capital it's that simple
your reputation and track record and the
relationships and associations who
validate you will attract the capital if
you don't have this there is no capital
simple you have to have a lot of this on
the front end to get the money number
seven they all had great initial
connections because it's all about the
contacts and connections my connections
were guys who went to the nightclub on a
weekly basis my connections were guys
who were chasing skirts my connections
were my boys that we would sit down
talk sports all day long and you know
play spades or play whatever cards a
hawk you know he could play all these
other games
that's my connections so who are my
connections I didn't go to university to
be part of in a long night what are my
connections my connections from the
military never ever introduced me to
anybody in business these are my
connections from military don't have a
business background who are my
connections connections are byproduct of
a lot of work of people senior saying
this guy's legit he's working hard
let's connect him to this person it's
not hey this person had a father who is
related to Vanderbilt and this person no
it does not work that way if you had
that it's an edge I had zero my parents
have never been entrepreneurs I don't
come from a business background my dad
stopped going to school after eighth
grade to up support his family I'm not
the smart kid down can't nothng none of
that stuff I had to work my tail off to
get my connections if you're looking for
shortcuts misconception okay number
seven numbers number eight it's a
massive risk I got to take such a
massive risk this is why I don't want to
become an entrepreneur I've seen so many
people lose everything and all this
other stuff yes there are a lot of
people that lose everything you're right
there are a lot of people that go all-in
you know and we always want to watch on
YouTube guys who go all-in who what who
win oh this guy went all-in what a smart
diamond this guy money make you out of
two five anyone all in anyone now that
guy's a great poker player okay there's
a little luck there right but you don't
have to go all-in every single time many
people can start a business part-time
while you have a job and you just start
testing your product and see how people
are responding to it anybody can start a
business part-time and work through it
you don't have to start fully full-time
when Apple gets started when I
interviewed Steve Wozniak we can put a
clip of when I interviewed Steve Wozniak
they started their business while he had
a full-time job
and Steve had a full-time job and they
started messing around with this thing
out of their garage and then it going to
say let's quit our jobs and Wozniak
didn't want to quit his job for a few
months but he finally did they started
part-time and I tested it you can't -
number nine last one is entrepreneurs
are their own boss everybody wants to
say I want to you know you become an
entrepreneur you're your own boss that
is a misconception you are now your own
boss you are now your own boss like when
people say when you have kids you're the
man of the household really your kids
tell you what to do you to drop them off
to school you have to pick them up in
the morning you get a lot more sleep if
you don't have kids they wake you up
three four times the middle now my
daughter
waking us up middle than I two or three
times there the boss I'm not the boss I
happen to support and fund their life
but they're my boss so as an
entrepreneur my customers are my boss I
have tens of thousands of customers that
are my boss I have thousands of sales
people that are my boss I have employees
that are my boss vendors and partners
have relationships they have the media
these are people that you yourself had
to learn how to support and the more the
better you improve in the more you grow
your business then the more leverage and
influence and Trust you have it's easy
to move your business but you are not
your own boss when it comes down to
running everything 100 percent of the
time that is a misconception of
entrepreneurship so look I can go on and
talk about many many more things when it
comes up to misconceptions my challenge
Q is don't let these nine misconceptions
prevent you from becoming an
entrepreneur share this video with
somebody else that maybe is on the verge
of saying I don't want to be an
entrepreneur they've set any of these
nine things have them watch this video
and have them think about it from a
completely different perspective because
unfortunately unfortunately
unfortunately many of these same
misconceptions prevent people from
living their dream life some kid asked
me yesterday and he said hey how's it
feel now having the life that you have
and I told him I said I was this close
I've just being a regular guy making
fifty to grandeur this close I was this
close this close regular guy regular got
a place that I'm gonna doing nothing is
grown nothing is expanding that I was
just closed I almost bought into this
misconceptions I almost did I almost was
convinced by my family friends and many
of the media and associations that I had
but I didn't do it I won't challenge you
to the same do the same as well now we
have a problem that I need your help
with we're in Texas right now without
our favorite pillow we left behind but
this is what we want to do with our
pillow and I'm putting the challenge out
there to everybody
who is a big value taemin fan this is
what we're doing I am looking for a new
pillow for 2017 a new subscribed pillow
for 2017 so I want hue I'm gonna give
credit to the pillow that we use I want
you to either find a nice pillow for
value to me that you can customize with
value today my logo on it and you two
blow gun or whatever it is bigger
smaller I don't care what
it's gonna be a good one that I hold and
it'll be yours for the rest of 2017 I
will hold that pillow so you can make it
custom make it have somebody make it I
don't care what it is you can buy one at
the store that's six seven bucks that
you'll like it you want to send it to us
anything you find I want you to send us
all the pillows okay here's the address
you can send it to 5,000 won
Spring Valley Road Suite number 11:55 e
11:55 P that's in Dallas Texas seven
five two four four we'll put the address
in the description as well send your
pillows our way make sure it's got
subscribe on them it could make sure
it's got by a Taemin be creative on
whatever way you want to do it but I'm
definitely looking forward to seeing
some of those pillows being sent over to
the headquarters again the address will
be on the bottom and if you haven't
subscribed to this channel please do so
you got any questions thoughts about
what I talked about today post your
comments on the bottom take everybody
bye-bye
you